la seine-saint-denis voit la vie en vert
le département vient d'inaugurer un
nouvel espace vert le bocage c'est son
nom est situé dans le parc du sausset
sur les communes de villepinte et donne
les sous bois un bocage pour se croire à
la campagne en pleine ville france
avouac aimant ce gel du blé et sa
lumière et sa sont beaux comme à la
campagne
coquelicot lavande et maïs dans le
bocage on est bien loin du parc
traditionnel pas d'aller mais des
chemins de terre et les mini champ de
fleurs font des clins d'oeil au passé
qui avait t-il sur ces lieux avant aussi
les cultures céréales essentiellement
bible avec des fermes existantes
s'il ya une activité tout à fait
traditionnelle comme celles qu'on peut
pas n'être plus loin de la région
parisienne est qui et qui s'est terminée
dans les airs
finalement la d1 les deux paysagistes
voulait garder le côté sauvage de la
végétation
les deux cours d'eau qui traversent le
parc le bocage constitue la deuxième
tranche de l'aménagement du parc
dussault s'est planté en 80 qu'il ya des
des prêts en plo de hockey qui les
protège à la fois qui donne une certaine
intimité plus des arbres que vous voyez
qui vont prendre un certain
développement parce que ce sont des
chaînes qui sont encore très jeunes
qu'ils ont été plantés il ya un an
des chaînes ou des noyers enfin des
arbres à apport est allé et les gens
pourront s'installer dans ces prairies
pique-niqué ou faire d'avoir une
pratique un peu formel c'est pas un parc
qui est très très structuré qui offre
des équipements construits
objectif du bocage donnée au site à une
certaine idée de la campagne et de ses
activités le projet initial prévoit
d'ailleurs d'installer une ferme et des
exploitants en attendant la moisson
précoce s'est faite cet après midi au
rythme des machines des années 40